hello and welcome to the shiki-san show
in this video I'll tell you about readme
files a lab tip to help your future you
so have you ever looked back at some of
your results and wondered how do they
analyze this data whether this results
come from all it's a figure and going
how did I generate this what did I click
on to get to this position
or looked at your Western blot scan and
wondered what exposures that are they
use for this now some of these points
might seem to review but how handy would
it be if there was a file in your
directory for each experiment that
actually explains which other files
contain and how you got to that position
and how you generated that data well why
don't you consider generating a readme
file so the point of a readme file is to
have all of this different information
in one location that is in an area that
contains all of the different figures
data points and analyses in the same
directory and so the points of the
readme file is to serve as a reference
but you can come back to a year later
when you can't remember the exact
details of how you process or generated
these files so what would be inside a
readme file so it includes you know the
simple things like what did I click on
to process my images what concentrations
of the small molecules in my experiment
I was using and how long did I do
something in my experiments and has they
actually process my data so the point of
the readme file is to kind of explain a
detail or enough detail for yourself of
how what is in each of your files in
your directory and so the purpose of
this is that you don't clog up the
actual data files that have the kind of
useful information but this readme file
is still going to be there so if you
come back to a date or a year later
thinking oh yeah that's how I did it and
off you go again so there are many
different formats that you can use for
your readme files I've simply used Y pod
here just because for me it's simplistic
and all I need to write down is pros but
if you wanted to put in coding if you
were using our studio for example you
can then make our markdowns and so you
very much do you know you can do ideas
the same it's just you've formats and
way that you want to use it that is most
beneficial to yourself I actually quite
liked how simple the slide pad is also
because at the top you can see it's got
this date and time panel which inserts
the right date so you haven't got to
keep making different versions of my
readme file I can just extend the file
that I've already got and also it saves
the file as a text file which means that
it can pretty much be opened in many
different applications should one of
these applications close down
okay passed so if you're not yet
convinced that making a readme file will
be beneficial then let me show you the
graph and so this is the graph I
recently saw in a different YouTube
video that was titled the graph that
changed my life and then basically
there's graph gaze into the idea of
delayed gratification and so if we take
a look at this graph like um making a
readme file you know it takes energy it
takes energy to be organized which is
why often we don't want to do these tiny
little details and write them down in
our lab book or make kids copies and
back up our data because it takes time
right it takes energy it takes time we
just want that sometimes go home have a
cup of tea and say you know we do these
things that in the moment give us like
that positive good life feeling but
later on as we well know we come back to
it again I don't really know what I did
and has negative long term consequences
however if we see the other sides we
make the readme file yes sure initially
it's gonna be a bit annoying but we come
back a year later and we go way I'm so
glad I made this file and if you do this
for all of your directories then no
matter what you come back to you you've
got a good starting position and so you
help your future self is the lesson from
today and say make some readme files
thanks for listening